[Music]
I am very excited to host the four live
podcast event and we are back in London
we've hired a fantastic venue we've got
a DJ again we've got fantastic panelists
in Ben Claire and Harry take a look
[Music]
so I'm with Lewis who attended the live
podcast event in London overall what did
you think of the event first of all it's
the the layout for me I think you come
in here it's not too serious it's very
um everyone's chatting to each other's
having a drink and enjoying themselves
there's a lot of people with smiles on
the face and and yeah obviously you'll
learn a lot from it by listening to
people and hearing from people who who
have a lot of knowledge and experience
in the market
foreign
from the higher group why did you come
why did you come to this event and made
the trip from Manchester been one year
into recruitment I think it's important
you know you want to learn everything
that's possible in this industry there's
a lot to learn it never stops it's good
to hear you know from Market
professionals kind of what tickles their
fancy What's working well for them just
absorbing the information you know
there's beer I've got chocolate in my
pocket I mean I I couldn't recommend it
enough I really couldn't
so I'm with Joe who also made the trip
from Manchester for the overall event
experience what did you think of it
um I love it I've been to all three now
like loyal fan I think it's just good
for everyone to get in a room together
and not be like a like competitive it's
not like I don't feel like you come here
to head on or you come here to Rob
business it's about sharing ideas
learning from people getting to know
each other and then you all start coming
a little bit more familiar
I'm with my good friend Michelle I'm
really delighted that you're here and
you're able to come why would you
recommend other recruiters to come to
the event
no-brainer it's like in in recruitment
it's a really difficult industry and why
not come to an event where you're going
to learn from the best of the best and
we get to have a good laugh whilst we're
doing it and there's a bar and there's a
DJ and we're a great venue so literally
why not
[Music]
so that is the end of another live
podcast event the audience are amazing
the panelists were fantastic I want to
say a massive thank you to our event
sponsors that make this all a reality
and PGC Salisbury convincere if you
weren't able to get to this one don't
worry there's gonna be plenty more to
keep your eyes peeled
[Music]